everyone welcome welcome welcome into
another edition of Market takes we are
today breaking down the big reports that
came out this morning we got PPI that's
U.S producer prices the producer price
index and we are also looking at U.S
retail sales two reports that came out
moved the market in a big way this
morning we're gonna break down just what
was in those reports what happened the
market reaction all that good stuff you
know we're going to talk through what
the report said I'm going to tell you
all the numbers uh what was important
why why it mattered what was moving what
wasn't what those moves mean do all that
good stuff we're going to talk about
what these reports tell us about the
state of inflation and the likelihood of
recession right here in the U.S of
course we're going to check out the
markets because the markets are what
tell us everything we need to know about
how investors are viewing this number in
light of the current market environment
so all you investors out there know
what's happening and why it's happening
and then of course I'm going to tell you
what to look out for next because even
though we're looking at backward looking
data we are always looking forward
toward the future here on Market takes
so listen I am Dion Robert Bowen
reporter at the Wall Street Journal I'm
your host for Market takes I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me and I appreciate
you for that listen diving first into
this retail sales report uh a big
decline in retail sales month over month
we saw that month over month decline of
1.1 percent uh expectations were for a
one percent decline which was pretty
significant I think a lot of folks
thought that would be maybe a little too
high well the decline was even bigger so
the decline from November from December
from to no I'm sorry the decline in
December from November was 1.1 after a
negative 0.6 reading in November from
October that was the lowest reading in a
year the lowest reading since December
2021 on the retail sales report and the
first back-to-back negative retail sales
reports since November and December of
2020. so typically what we've had over
the past year really two years is even
when there's a bad month on the retail
sales report we get a good month that
follows it this year we're seeing or at
the end of last year really we saw
back-to-back negative reports and again
expectations for economic growth to
decline this year expectations for job
reports for those job growth numbers to
start slowing down we are really seeing
some more worrisome signs of recession
and this U.S retail sales report was
another one that suggests that wow the
economy is really slowing down however
and there's always a there's always a
but right even though I said however uh
year over year retail sales have been
slowing but we still saw a pickup of
about six percent year over year on that
retail sales number and again while
we're seeing a decline a pretty
significant decline a slowing decline of
the gain retail sales are still up in a
big way year over year so when you
compare to where we were at the end of
2021 well retail sales still pretty high
businesses are still doing a lot of
sales still moving a lot of product
whether you talk about this The Goods
the services sector but we're seeing
that decline slow pretty significantly
we're also seeing you know in December
that's usually a big month retailers
make a lot of their money for the year
in December and that decline in retail
sales shows that retailers are facing a
trying and challenging environment as
they moved out of 2022 and into
2023. uh now we look at that PPI report
also a larger than expected month over
month month decline we saw a 0.5 percent
month over month decrease on PPI that
producer price index basically what
businesses pay for their inputs you know
if you are a company that makes uh photo
frames what you're paying for steel
glass those sorts of things those prices
decline by half a percent month over
month but an increase of 6.2 percent
year over year which is what people
typically talk about when they talk
about PPI that is down significantly
from that big 11.3 percent reading we
got in June so about knocking almost
half of that off in just about half a
year that is a pretty significant
decline this is well below expectations
for the month over month and the year
over year level on PPI so again we're
missing below expectations on retail
sales and PPI not great things when it
comes to the economy but we are seeing
the markets up I'm going to talk about
why that is in just a moment so first
off I want to talk about why these
reports matter we've talked about the
expectations for recession or Rising
inflation right now the market has
decided and investors really have as
they're looking out decided that
inflation and continued inflation that
just proceeds higher and higher is a
worse thing than a potential recession
the idea here is that if we do have a
recession it'll be a pretty shallow one
a pretty narrow one the FED will reverse
course start cutting rates that'll be
good for the market stock prices will
rise investors will be jubilant and and
things can kind of move back into the
room realm of normalcy if inflation just
keeps Rising higher well the fed's going
to have to keep raising rates to try to
tackle inflation that could push us into
a prolonged recession a deeper harsher
darker recession and so investors are
really pricing okay maybe we have to
have a recession you know here and now
in 2023 but that's going to lead to good
things in the future so pricing down
some of these reports like the U.S
retail sales report like this PPI report
is a good thing and it's got investors
pretty excited so the PPI report the PPI
report excuse me shows inflation is is
slowing faster than expected and the
retail sales report shows that as well
that is a good thing for investors a
good thing for the market so this
continues The Narrative that we've seen
from CPI the Consumer Price Index
continues the narrow that we saw in the
jobs report with that declining wages
the declining average hourly earnings in
the jobs report and a slowing jobs added
number that we saw from the jobs report
we're seeing can continue data show that
inflation is coming down is coming down
faster than expected and that's a good
thing for the market I do want to note
though again another but when we look at
this PPI report something the Bureau of
Labor Statistics mentioned in the second
paragraph of the support that's very
unusual they don't usually do things
like this they pointed out quote in
December the decrease in final demand
index in the sorry the decrease in the
final demand index can be attributed to
a 1.6 percent decline in prices for
final demand Goods in contrast the index
for final demand Services Rose 0.1
percent why does that matter because the
Federal Reserve has very predictably or
sorry has very much pointed to Services
they say hey we need to keep raising
rates yeah goods are coming down faster
than expected yeah overall inflation is
coming down but that's just because good
prices are coming down those Services
prices they are still picking up and so
when you see this number when you see
the BLS in the second paragraph of the
report again they don't you usually do
this say Okay Goods prices are coming
down yeah at a big fast rate 1.6 percent
that's very big on a month over month
level but Services actually increased
and the Federal Reserve has really
pointed to that Services inflation
because Services make up about 80
percent of the US economy so when 80 of
the economy is still seeing price
increases that doesn't suggest that
there is overall going to be sustainable
moves lower in inflation and that once
these good Goods prices come down
significantly or come down enough well
that's just going to stop moving the
index because if Services keep Rising
you're going to see it kind of either
tail off or maybe start to pick up again
and that's what the Federal Reserve is
worried about Investors ought to keep
that in the back of their minds yes we
saw the overall index decline but that's
because Goods prices largely Vehicles
especially used cars and trucks things
that have just shot up and were not
sustainable prices for a long time
those have started to come back down to
earth housing prices are coming down a
little bit but still very inflated from
a historical perspective so when we see
the BLS pointing out the differentiation
in goods and services well the FED is
pointing out the difference in goods and
services and so maybe it's not time to
be super excited about this PPI report
that's the big thing about Goods versus
Services as investors we've got to start
looking in between the lines and reading
between those okay yeah yeah the overall
the headline number blah blah blah when
you see that okay that's one thing to
keep in mind but when you dig in deeper
to the report the services component's
still Rising look for Fed chair Jerome
Powell maybe talk about that at the
fed's next press conference you know
we'll be breaking down here on Market
takes February 1st
um now a big thing within both reports
both PPI and retail sales is gasoline
gas prices have come down significantly
over the past few months and that feeds
into everything so gas again it's on
that good side used trucks used cars
those are on that good Site Services
haircuts lawyer services accountants all
those things that's picking up and
continuing to rise and the FED is going
to be fixated on that so we've talked a
lot about okay well here's what we need
to look at for the market let's talk
about the market right now in the
response that we have seen we are seeing
continued strength from the NASDAQ the
NASDAQ about one percent right now the
Dow up just about just about flat
actually was about point one percent but
we're seeing a lot of those gains in the
Dow kind of Fade Away NASDAQ is jumping
one percent yesterday if you were
watching the market the Dow fell overall
by about 400 points the NASDAQ Rose and
we are seeing continued strength in the
NASDAQ that's those risky tech stocks
that have been hit hard by these
expectations for the Federal Reserve to
keep raising rates and keep interest
High keep interest rates High we are now
seeing those stocks rebound we are
seeing a a real flight to risk people
talk about a flight to Quality right now
we're seeing a flight to risk with those
tech stocks up some of those big risky
companies that got hit really hard right
as the Fed was raising rates now as
inflation comes down faster than
expected folks are buying those Tech
names buying some of that risk and we
are seeing consistent strength in
overall risk sector so the s p ended
last week up 4.2 percent year-to-date
the NASDAQ was on its longest winning
streak since November 8 2021 going into
yesterday and it has continued that
winning streak uh its longest winning
streak in 2021 was 11 straight days year
to date S P 500 up about four percent
NASDAQ of about six percent and again
we're up another one percent this
morning now that could change some folks
would come in and moderate you could see
some big sales but what we're seeing
right now is a continued increase in
Risk appetite folks wanting to take on
risk buy those risky things like
high-flying tech stocks we're also
seeing that in crypto which we'll get to
in just a minute uh we are seeing in the
treasury market as we look into bonds
the real Market if you know me and you
know I love bonds we are seeing those
yields come down significantly
especially in what's known as the belly
of the curve the belly is those three
five seven year notes we are seeing the
the five year note actually down about
18 basis points today uh leading all
bond yields coming down we're seeing the
10-year down about 12 basis points so
yields coming down which means prices
rise which means Bond Bond investors are
buying we're seeing a real rally right
now in the treasury market with bond
yields coming down uh really you got the
two-year the tenure and across the board
bond yields are the lowest they've been
since about September so this is more
good news that inflation is coming down
and really folks in the bond market are
excited in buying we have seen
significant moves there over the past
couple weeks really as the year has
started uh Bond investors have been
buying in a big way as we look out at
the currency Market we are also seeing
some of the the reflected you know sort
of loss of luster of the US dollar as
those yields come down the dollar value
comes down we're seeing the Euro backup
near 109 1085 highest it's been in quite
some time some of the the gains in the
Japanese Yen are sort of starting to
fade away that's that's a an other story
with the bank of Japan we don't have to
get into that too much
um but we're seeing the dollar Index
down about half a percent right now the
wsj dollar Index down half percent the
U.S dollar Index usdxy as it's known or
Dixie for some of y'all in the know uh
that's down about point six percent
difference between Dixie and the wsj
dollar Index is just that wsj matches it
with about 16 currencies around the
world so you get a broader picture of
what the dollar is doing the dollar
Index which is more used by Traders that
really uses more the Euro and some of
those G10 currencies the larger
countries a lot of those European
countries uh the dollar the British
pound things like that factor in a lot
more to the movement so we are also
saying I want to point to really quickly
crypto and the cryptocurrency market
which has just been exploding uh over
the past really to start this year
overseeing ether up a little over one
percent Bitcoin up about point eight
percent we have seen gains from crypto
this year that have really put the
market back in a strong Place Bitcoin
back up over 20 000 ether approaching
just a smidge under 1600 uh we're seeing
some of those gains in the crypto market
and that is despite a very overall
negative story in crypto look you talk
about FTX you talk about Genesis you
talk about block 5 Celsius uh those
companies really hurting in a bad way
and underneath the ground uh CR ftx's
founder is has been indicted and sent to
the US is facing criminal charges so
some of the biggest names in all of the
crypto space are facing a lot of trouble
you're seeing really an implosion of the
crypto Market space in terms of the
businesses around it and still you see
Bitcoin back up over twenty thousand you
see ethereum up near 1600 this is the
highest some of these uh
cryptocurrencies have been in a very
long time dating back to October and if
Bitcoin keeps on the path that it's
going we could start to see Bitcoin
moving back towards some of those highs
that we hadn't seen since June of last
year when we got that huge Swan Dive In
crypto so like I said risk is in Vogue
right now folks are buying thinking that
inflation's coming down and that the
Federal Reserve is going to back off of
its plan to raise rates and keep them
high over the course of this year that's
the big picture so listen I always talk
about what comes next because you know
we're always looking forward here's what
comes next tomorrow we get the housing
starts report That's Thursday morning
that's going to tell us a lot about the
housing market which has been really
declining significantly and showing the
wear and tear of those fed interest
rates interest rate hikes now if that
report shows a positive number you could
see the market sort of move in the
opposite direction because investors
right now really want to buy and they
want to buy risk but that could be a
report that really turns things around
because housing has been the one major
asset class that has responded pretty
significantly to what the FED has done
now even more important I think than
that housing starts or any other data
that you'll see we have Fed chair fed
Vice chair excuse me Leo Brainerd
talking tomorrow at the University of
Chicago and New York fed President John
Williams is speaking at an event uh
those are both going to be tomorrow
you're going to watch those those are
going to move the market if Fed chair
Leo brainer she's much more
representative of the rest of the
committee fed New York fed President
John John Williams very representative
and often in League with Fed chair
Jerome Powell if they say Hey you know
we're we're getting a little iffy on
these rate hikes we might want to you
know back off you could see the market
really explode and turn higher if on the
other hand they both or you know fed New
York fed President John Williams has
been more hawkish trying to keep rates
high if they both say you know what we
still need to do more we're going to
keep going on what we're going uh you
could see the market really turn lower
or maybe just not get much of a boost
but watch both of those speakers
tomorrow watch for the headlines coming
out of those we got got existing home
sales on Friday leading economic
indicators on Monday that's going to be
a big one and then we will be right here
doing Market takes for you when we've
got the usq4 GDP report that is next
week be sure and be here don't be a
that's a square don't be a square and
join us on Market takes listen that's
going to do it for me I am Dion Robert
Bowen this has been Market takes thank
you so much for tuning in with us and we
hope to see you next time right here on
Market takes